alors on le voit c'est pénible dans
plusieurs secteurs d'ailleurs selon une
étude des économistes de desjardins le
niveau alors le retour aux niveaux
d'activité économique prévalait avant la
part des vies n'est pas prévue avant
juin 2022
et ce scénario comporte toutefois un
risque l'ampleur d'une éventuelle
deuxième vague d'accords 8,19 desjardins
d'ailleurs annoncé aujourd'hui un plan
d'action pour accompagner ses membres
est avec nous d'ailleurs guy cormier qui
est président et chef de la direction du
mouvement desjardins cela nous fait
plaisir mais ce cormier nous accueillir
- merci beaucoup
donc pas de retour à la normale donc
complet avant deux à il faudrait être
patient
ce sera graduelle et toutes les régions
du québec n'avons pas progressé de la
même façon exactement c'est pas demain
l'une des premières fois dans les 50 60
dernières années qu'on voit une sortie
de récession où la croissance va être
aussi non non symétrique il ya des
secteurs d'activité des régions qui vont
aller bien appuyé mais déjà le constat
et des entreprises sont déjà revenus
plus complet ouais carnet de commandes
est plein ça carbure et vous allez voir
d'autres secteurs d'activité on peut
penser l'aviation les routes du canton
et les mêmes qui vont être plus de
difficultés c'est vrai un peu plus long
alors tu n'es pas que charnière
actuellement à la une grande crise
économique sanitaire ce que vous
ressentez l'importance comme dirigeant
desjardins n'est pas encore plus présent
pour les québécois on a fait des années
on a mis des mesures très rapidement dès
le 16 mars et on est en constante
communication avec nos membres et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on relance un
autre message à nos membres nos clients
qu'ils peuvent compter sur nous que les
mesures d'allégement qu'on a misé
l'avant pourront se poursuivre
évidemment il y avoir des ajustements
l'on voit qu'avec la schl estime de
mesures qui vont changer
non vraiment vouloir accompagner nos
membres les prêts d'urgence
l'accompagnement des entrepreneurs au
niveau de tarification qui vont être
créés coved et non pas en fonction de la
situation actuelle j'ai entre eux mêmes
dans une tournée de chacune des régions
et que la fédération des chambres de
commerce pour aller au devant des
régions et des entrepreneurs pour
continuer d'écouter puis voir qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire encore pour des
accompagne encore mieux il ya des choses
qui restent notamment une enveloppe de
150 millions $ pour des projets que son
portail sas avait annoncé
d'avril à vous avez commencé à nommer
certaines des mesures pour soulager les
particuliers des reports de paiement
notamment également aussi le pour les
gens qui ont vraiment des difficultés
financières exactement et coûter jusqu'à
maintenant c'est plus de 300 mille
demandes d'allègement sony blessures les
cartes de crédit que nous avons autorisé
plus de 4000 entreprises ont bénéficié
de mesures qu'on s'améliore la wii c'est
sur un juillet ou le monde vu un
ralentissement des demandes d'allègement
hauteur pour les entreprises que pour
les particuliers
une fois que j'ai dit ça ya encore des
gens qui ont des besoins et notre vol à
nous c'est de les accompagner
alors s'il ya des demandes qui vont être
faire brutaliser cas par cas parce que
souvent les gens nous appellent avec une
idée puis après avoir discuté aux
conseillers ben et moi qui ai peut-être
d'autres solutions notamment au niveau
de leur entreprise alors on va continuer
les accompagner dans les prochaines
prochaine semaine prochaine
il fait des gens ils nous écoutent
actuellement le qui ont des difficultés
financières qu'est ce qu'on va faire on
appelle carrément donc sa succursale saq
à istres on appelle ça qu on appelle 1
800 cas elles en expriment l'enjeu qu'on
vit actuellement et nous on a un panier
de solutions aux bourdes et accompagné
il ya des programmes gouvernementaux qui
existe c'est autant vrai pour des
individus que pour des entreprises et ça
fait quatre cinq six mois confesseur
notre message aujourd'hui c'est que on
sait ce report sauf dans quelques jours
on veut continuer de vous accompagner
les allées contre les têtes un petit mot
sur le taux d'endettement qui a grimpé
un rapport aujourd'hui c'est surtout
reliées aux prêts hypothécaires et
qu'est-ce que vous avez remarqué vous
cherchez des jardins écouter au niveau
de payement la demande hypothécaire chez
desjardins
le début de l'année est encore une fois
assez extraordinaire qui a produit de
pandémie à nos volumes sont à la hausse
il ya eu un délai l'onr comprendre que
de mars à juin il remet un
ralentissement mais on a vraiment vu en
juillet et un nous où on est en mesure
de votre progression
on voit que larry page en quelque sorte
où le film oui exactement dans la vente
automobile
les propriétés ya une réalité il ya des
gens qui ont malheureusement perdu leur
emploi mais il ya encore plusieurs
personnes qui ont conservé leur emploi
alors il regarde les opportunités qu'ils
ont sur le marché puis d'imposition des
jardins étant celle de leadership au
québec il vienne et vienne sur un très
naturellement chez nous alors
l'endettement nous préoccupe lumière
jaune qui scintille sur notre radar mais
ce qu'on a vu aux retards de paiement
pas nécessairement
autre sujet chaud on a vu hier que les
fraudes qui sont reliés à la pétition
doublé au mois d'août donc se sont
prêtés au niveau canadien mais à
davantage de fraudes au québec dont les
gens qui se sont fait subtiliser
carrément leur identité par des escrocs
on le sait il ya eu un vol de données
chez desjardins est ce qu'on peut y voir
un lien monsieur cormier a écouté
essentiellement le s qui est lié avec
desjardins est ce qu'il ya un lièvre
capitaux juanes qui le liait avec le
ministère de l'éducation du québec et à
québec canada
actuellement la réalité malheureusement
c'est qu'à chaque semaine on one
entreprise ou une organisation qui évite
alors c'est difficile et je sais que les
gens considéraient ce qui s'est passé
chez desjardins on fait des liens c'est
très difficile
une fois que la fuite ait fait de savoir
ce qui s'est passé alors nous c'est pour
ça qu'on a lancé la protection des
jardins une protection qui accompagne
les jeunes aux gens appelez nous puis on
voit si une transaction douteuse dans
votre compte
on va vous rembourser s'il ya eu des
transactions non autorisées on vous
rembourse ils pourront un service
d'accompagnement personnalisé c'est leur
manque une journée de travail ou à avoir
des frères elias donc on voit de cette
protection est fait le travail parce que
des gens qui viennent nous voir qu'ils
disent écoutez je suis mal chez
desjardins pouvez vous m'aider je suis
pas du tout que c'est un enseignant ou
sims
alors je pense que c'est un service faut
offrir de mieux desservir ces des
mesures qui ont été adoptées mais vous
pourrez pas nous donner l'assurance
aujourd'hui que nous donner ne se
promènent pas à gauche et à droite
actuellement
d'un côté il ya des enquêtes policières
qui sont en cours on voit que les gens
poursuivent leurs travaux
nous chez desjardins on a mis des mois
de décembre un bureau de la sécurité
plus de 900 personnes travaillent dans
ce bureau actuellement l'un des gens qui
sont spécialisés en cybercriminalité en
encaisse en lutte au blanchiment
d'argent
alors ce groupe là vraiment un rôle
majeur dans notre organisation pour
justement avoir toujours les meilleurs
standards au niveau de l'industrie et
être capable d'apprendre à des
situations qui se passe à travers de
mongkok d'associer des mesures concrètes
qu'on a mise là
ce qu'on sait si nos données
personnelles ont été transférés un tiers
monsieur cormier ce que vous avez ce
type d'importations la cette information
je sais que c'est un format je sais que
des données ont sorti de chez desjardins
où elles sont allées par la suite j'ai
pas cette information
possiblement vous pouvez la voir parce
que vous ne vous dites qu'une équipe qui
travaille spécifiquement là dessus
actuellement pas été là je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus haut niveau de
l'enquêté policière l'enquêté policière
qui se fait actuellement pour voir
comment aurait pu s'opérer la suite
latin je pense que c'est beaucoup
beaucoup sur cette enquête
on va avoir plus d'informations et en
terminant monsieur cormier ça fait 4 à
peu près quatre ans je crois que vous
êtes à l'appel de desjardins
vous attendiez sûrement pas à vivre donc
évidemment ce vol de données mais aussi
donc la pandémie mondiale
en quelque sorte une tempête parfaite
comment on se sent comme diriger ce
qu'on a à gérer tout cela à écouter les
gens souvent les gens comme douze mois
que vous êtes en gestion on vieillit on
vieillit plus vite mais on attend on
apprend beaucoup et puis on va chercher
des outils qu'on découvre qu'on appuie
vous savez ce pas le travail d'une
personne c'est un travail d'équipé chez
desjardins il ya plein de gens qui
m'accompagnent
jacky mind que moi quand je regarde la
confiance que les membres des clients
continuent de témoigner à chaque jour
envers notre organisation vers notre
mouvement ça me donne juste confiance
d'en faire toujours plus tout simplement
dit cormier merci beaucoup de vent
étaient avec nous c'est aussi ça me fait
plaisir